familiares y colectivos de indígenas
pidieron este lunes la liberación de
maricela lópez bautista
se trata de una mujer indígena tzotzil
que el 20 de noviembre de 2019 mató a su
marido éste estaba afilando su machete
borracho y drogado y ella respondió con
un leño la realidad de los hechos es que
marisela ese día lo que hizo fue
defender su vida la vida del bebé que
llevaba en el vientre porque ella estaba
embarazada de seis meses y la vida de
sus otros dos chiquititos menores de
edad el 19 de abril un juzgado de san
cristóbal de las casas en el sureño
estado de chiapas la condenó a 25 años
de prisión los manifestantes denuncian
que no se tuvieron en cuenta las pruebas
que evidenciaban la continua violencia
que recibía también argumentan que no
tuvo un juicio justo
el caso de marisela es uno de los tantos
casos que existe en mexico de mujeres de
hombres que no han tenido la oportunidad
de tener un intérprete con perspectiva
de género con mirada intercultural
méxico vive una crisis de violencia
machista según la onu cada día son
asesinadas 10 mujeres mientras según
organizaciones hay una impunidad entre
el 97 y el 99 por ciento de los casos en
el gobierno de andrés manuel lópez
obrador los feminicidios se han
disparado este ha culpado al
neoliberalismo pero los colectivos
feministas acusan a los recortes en
programas contra la violencia machista